when the Shanghai dragons won this past
weekend I know you were things the same
thing that I was how does the worst
esports team in the world turn it all
around
well the answer is more complicated than
you might think obviously the players
were incredible but the unsung heroes of
the Shanghai Dragons comeback were the
coaching staff into management
but sometimes eSports fans are a little
hesitant to give those behind-the-scenes
forces their due
[Music]
so if you don't follow the overwatch
League here's what happened this past
weekend the Shanghai dragons most famous
for going completely winless in season
one of the league with an O 140 record
defeated the New York excelsior the
vancouver titans and the san francisco
shocked to win the season two stage
three playoffs in English the worst team
in the history of eSports beat three of
the best teams in their league to win a
championship with literally zero
contacts this is already super
impressive Shanghai's oh and forty
season is the stuff of legends they are
unquestionably the worse eSports team of
all time and probably the worst
professional sports team too
no matter how bad you think they were
they were so so much worse
look we've literally made an entire
video about how they managed to go
completely winless during a season so
you can watch that for more info but for
now all you really need to know is that
they sucked so so bad so their win this
weekend is pretty crazy right well a lot
of people were quick to point out that
it wasn't as impressive as it seemed on
paper because the six players who won
that championship this weekend weren't
on the team at all during their winless
season notably over watch league caster
monte cristo tweeted that he didn't want
to hear any 142 staged finals [ __ ]
about the Shanghai dragons run now I
understand what he's saying he totally
makes sense and he gives the management
their due but I do think there is a
storyline here after all the management
had to put their trust in a new coach
who put his trust in a new team and
built strategies and synergies that
these players could pull off to make it
to the finals look this is still an
impressive feat obviously the players
played incredibly this weekend but the
coaching staff deserves their credit -
look I am NOT the world's foremost
overwatch analyst but as far as I can
tell this all started in September of
2018 when the Dragons brought on blue
Haas to be their new head coach
replacing a string of let's say
controversial coaches the team also
dumped eight of their 11 players
choosing to rebuild with a majority of
the calm due Pantera roster Korean
contenders came and blew Hassan former
team along with diem from lucky future
zenith and gam suit the former League of
Legends Pro and Boston uprising tank
Shanghai had a slow start to the season
but blue Hassan roster slowly clicked as
he learned each player's individual
preferences in a world dominated by
goats blue Haas and his assistant coach
Levi's chose to focus on coordination
and those individual synergies between
their players for example Shanghai
quickly became known for breaking of the
meta they are one of the first teams to
run so more alongside ghosts which is
now standard and they were early to the
triple dps comp which has become pretty
standard as well in the o WL meta mu
Haas and Levi were great at finding out
what their players were individually
good at and getting the rest their
players to coordinate around those
strengths there's a lot of super
complicated meta stuff that we don't
really need to get into like how gamsu
gets less resources and some other tanks
in the league or how ding and DM use far
and widowmaker to herd their opponents
into specific parts of the map but the
point is that the coaching and
management staff took a bunch of
contenders level players and turn them
into a championship team also they
played dufus which i think is pretty
cool obviously this isn't the first time
something like this has happened
coaching and management are important
parts of any east for team success cloud
lines roster swap in league of legends
last year where they temporarily
banished a bunch of their superstars in
favor of players from their academy team
is a perfect example of this
they went from last in the standings to
Worlds obviously all the individual
pieces were great in that team but it
took a clever coach like Reaper to put
them all together and motivate them to
win meanwhile fans are willing to write
off a team as being completely different
when only the roster or even some
members of the roster have changed look
when the majority or even the entire
roster leaves your favorite team the
identity of that team is going to change
but management is still there and even
if they've brought in a new coach
they're still the same franchise and you
see that in sports all the time you see
this kind of sentiment all the time in
eSports when a majority of the roster or
even the entire roster changes people
are willing to say it's not the same
team anymore but in a franchise system I
just don't think that makes sense
look I literally don't know anything
about sports but smart people who do
know about sports tell me that this kind
of thing happens all the time there and
is celebrated 2015-2016 Leicester City
leonine Celtics or even the rapture is
this past year who dumped their coach
who was named coach of the year and
their franchise player in favor of a new
coach and a hired gun and won a
championship AHA that kind of savvy
management good coaching and knowledge
to acquire good players and synergize
address to your team is celebrated all
the time in sports people literally make
it into the Hall of Fame for being
builders and look I know that coaches
are celebrated in eSports but often not
to the same degree that I think they
should be I know
the Shanghai dragons who won say sri
this weekend aren't the shanghai dragons
that went oh and 40 last year but that's
the point the management didn't want
them to be so they picked up coaches who
they thought could turn the franchise
around and those coaches hand-picked a
roster that they thought could win a
championship and molded them into a team
that could beat the very best I don't
know I still think that's a pretty
incredible story line thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you will find anywhere else hit
up our Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages
[Music]